late last month president biden signed
into law the emmett till anti-lynching
act making lynching a federal hate crime
that is great news that it is also 400
years overdue
now why exactly did it take so long i'll
explain in a segment called how did we
get here
the emmett till anti-lynching act was
signed into law on march 29 2022 it's
definitely good news but it does feel a
little surprising that it just happened
it's like finding out we just passed a
law saying you can't lie to daycare on
fire like how was that not already the
law
the anti-lynching act actually passed
the house by a vote of 422-3
and pass the senate by unanimous consent
it sounds easy so why did it take so
long the short answer of course is
racism the long answer is racism but
with more details so
let's take a look at why it took
congress over a century to pass an
anti-lynching bill and why it still
matters
to do that we need to go back to the
beginning of the last century you know
when it was totally normal to name your
baby herman and people used to rock out
to this
[Music]
you think you can't twerk to that you
could talk to that
in the year 1900 the first anti-lynching
bill was presented to congress by george
henry white a representative from north
carolina now you might not be able to
tell but for his day and age this man
was a fox in 2022 he's a three but in
1900 he was an 11.
now to set the scene there had been
unrest in white's district which
included wilmington north carolina
wilmington had a mostly black population
and many black government officials the
black community there was filled with
doctors and lawyers and people who owned
prosperous businesses and if you've ever
seen this show before i think you know
where this is going it's the same
feeling you get when a white person is
about to give their thoughts on the will
smith chris rock slap it's gonna end
poorly
black families in wilmington became
successful and their white neighbors
were not having it so white supremacist
groups in the area published something
they called the white declaration of
independence which correct me if i'm
wrong here is just the declaration of
independence
anyway their version said that white men
had to be given black men's jobs in
businesses which is insane basically the
business community in wilmington was a
lot like the word bay created by black
people but as soon as it got big white
people had to find a way to ruin it
and that's exactly what they did a white
mob stormed through the streets of
wilmington shooting into the homes and
schools of black residents they
violently seized control of the
government and installed unelected white
people to replace black officials mobs
ravaged the entire city lynching
anywhere from dozens to hundreds of
black residents that is the environment
in which george henry white introduced
the first anti-lynching bill to congress
as a black man who had just watched his
constituents being lynched in the
streets and yet the bill never made it
out of committee congress refused to
even have the conversation when he left
congress a few years a few years later
george henry white would be the last
black person in congress for almost
three decades because you know the old
saying once you go black white people
throw a huge tantrum and don't elect
another black person for an entire
generation
might not be catchy but it's true now
that was just the first try after the
bill's failure it took 20 years before
another anti-lynching bill was
introduced into congress this time it
took the work of the naacp and a
missouri representative named leonidas
dyer dyer also had seen attacks on his
black constituents including the east st
louis race riots in which 38
african-american men women and children
were murdered by a white mob
dyer's bill did it did actually make it
out of committee and even passed in the
house in 1922 but it was stalled by
racists in congress who claimed that the
anti-lynching bill was and i swear this
is true an act of legislative mob
violence which is insane that's not just
the pot calling the kettle black it's
the pot lynching the kettle and then
complaining about pan on pin violence
unfortunately the stories go on like
this for the next century anti-lynching
bills emerged every decade or two like
cicadas or revivals of annie and
and just like annie there were a lot of
white guys embarrassing themselves by
being on the wrong side of history
mr warbucks you are an aging bald guy
constantly hitting on your much younger
assistant you are a cliche and a walking
sexual harassment lawsuit find a woman
who isn't your employee and stop asking
everybody to call you daddy you freaking
creep
the fact is almost 200 anti-lynching
bills were introduced in the first half
of the 20th century seven presidents
petitioned congress to end lynching
sometimes the bills would actually pass
the house but they always got blocked by
the senate and by the way you know how i
know all that because it's from the text
of a resolution the senate passed in
2005 apologizing for the fact that they
never passed an anti-lynching bill
that's right they passed a resolution
apologizing for not passing an
anti-lynching bill but they still didn't
pass an anti-lynching bill that's nuts
man
it's like lifeguards apologizing to
someone for all the shark attacks while
the shark is still chewing off their leg
get your priorities straight
now you've probably noticed that i
haven't really gotten into the details
of lynching in this piece well that's
because once you talk about exactly what
happened it's hard to make jokes but the
details matter
more than 4 000 people were lynched in
the united states between 1882 and 1968
and 99 of perpetrators escaped state or
local punishment the equal justice
initiative described some of these
lynchings as carnival-like events where
vendors sold food photographers printed
postcards and victims clothing and body
parts were given out as souvenirs
lynching has basically been an open moon
for our country yes it hurts to deal
with it but it will get so much worse if
we don't then naacp defines lynching as
the public killing of an individual who
has not received any due process so yeah
that includes our ancestors who were
hanged from trees but it also includes
modern day black people who were
murdered while they were taking out
their wallet wearing a hoodie or jogging
in their neighborhood or just minding
their own dang business
the emmett till anti-lynching act was
signed into law last month all it took
was 200 attempts
122 years and thousands upon thousands
of lynchings i'm glad it finally got
passed but we have to remember exactly
how we got here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you